hey everyone welcome back to another
video by simply learn today we are
diving into the exciting world of cyber
security we are protecting valuable data
and information is more crucial than
ever but before we jump into the
essentials of cyber defense let's first
understand what cyber security is before
moving forward let me ask you a quick
question so which of the following is
not an example of common cyber security
threat option A is phishing option b is
malware option C is firewall or option D
is ransomware you can pause this video
and answer in the comment section below
alright so now let's begin with the
first topic that is what is cyber
security so cyber security refers to the
practices and Technologies used to
protect computers networks and digital
information from unauthorized access
theft damage or disruption it is like
digital lock and a key system that keeps
your personal and sensitive information
safe from hackers and other cyber
threats just like you lock the doors of
your house to keep the thieves out cyber
security keeps hackers out of your
digital world it involves things like
using strong passwords keeping software
up to date and being cautious when
opening email attachments and clicking
on the links the cyber security Market
size is expected to reach 400 billion by
2028 as per Global Market insights
organizations and businesses also have a
responsibility to implement cyber
security measures to protect their
customers data and prevent cyber attacks
that could harm their reputation and
financial stability some of the popular
companies with a very high demand of
cyber security Engineers are semantic
rapid 7 FireEye Microsoft and coal fire
Etc now career scope of cyber security
the career scope of cyber security is
vast and ever expanding due to the
increasing Reliance on technology and
growing threat of cyber crime cyber
Security Professionals are in high
demand across various Industries and
sectors including government Finance
Health Care e-commerce and Technology
the demand for cyber Security
Professionals is expected to continue to
grow as organizations increasingly
prioritize protecting their data data
and systems from cyber threats now let's
talk about a topic that's on everyone's
mind that is cyber security salaries
there are various roles in the field of
cyber security each with its own
responsibilities and corresponding
salary ranges let's discuss some common
cyber security rules and their
approximate salary ranges first is
ethical hacker ethical hackers are cyber
security professionals who are
responsible for accessing the security
of computer systems networks
applications and other digital assets to
identify vulnerabilities they perform
authorized legal and controlled hacking
activities to file vulnerabilities and
report them to the organization for
remediation the average salary of an
ethical hacker is around 16 lakhs in
India and 88 000 in the United States
next is security engineer a security
engineer plays a critical role in
ensuring the security and integrity of
an organization Information Systems
networks and data their responsibilities
typically include designing and
implementing security measures
monitoring and detecting security
breaches Etc the average salary salary
of a security engineer is around 8 lakhs
in India and 120 000 in the United
States next up we have Chief Information
Security Officer the Chief Information
Security Officer or ciso is a senior
leadership role responsible for
overseeing the organization's
information security strategy policies
and programs the ciso is accountable for
ensuring the confidentiality Integrity
of the organization information
protecting them from cyber security
threats the average salary of a chief
information security officer is around
76 lakhs in India and 186 thousand
dollars in the United States the next
rule is network security engineer a
network security engineer is responsible
for managing and securing the
connections and communication between
devices computers over the Internet they
play a crucial role in implementing and
maintaining security measures that
Safeguard network connections and ensure
the protection of sensitive information
transmitted over the Internet the salary
of a network security engineer is around
6 lakhs in India and 101 thousand
dollars in the United States now moving
on to the next role that is I.T security
specialist and ID security specialist
collaborates with the team of IIT
professionals to create strategies and
plans for safeguarding devices and
systems with an organization against
cyber attacks they conduct assessments
of the ID systems to identify potential
vulnerabilities and work with the team
to strengthen the security posture of
the organization's ID environment the
average salary of an I.T security
specialist is around 12 lakhs in India
and 112 000 in the United States so
these are the various roles in the cyber
security and along with these there are
many other roles also next we have is
certification required for this field so
there are numerous certifications like
cyber security expert master's program
certified information security manager
Caltech cyber security bootcamp
offensive security certified
professional and ejpt V2 Etc now let's
have a look at them first is cyber
security Masters program this master's
program in cyber security will provide
you with all the necessary skills to
excel in the rapidly expanding field of
cyber security through this
comprehensive program you will learn how
to safeguard your infrastructure by
implementing robust measures to protect
data and information conducting through
risk analysis and mitigation designing
cloud-based security systems ensuring
compliance and much more next is
certified information security manager
offered by the information system audit
and Control Association cism is
certification that validates an
individual's expertise in information
security governance risk management and
information security program management
following is Caltech cyber security boot
camp by simpler this Caltech cyber
security bootcamp will help you gain the
skills and experience required by the
organization to protect their critical
systems and sensitive data from cyber
attacks through real world projects in
just 26 weeks this boot camp will help
you develop expertise in both defensive
and offensive cyber security digital
forensics penetration testing
infrastructure design and much more the
course curriculum labs and assisted
practices expose you to several
in-demand cyber security tools next up
we have is offensive security certified
professional offered by offensive
security oscp is a certification that
focuses on offensive security skills
including ethical hacking penetration
testing and explore development it
requires Hands-On practical skills and
is known for its challenging
certification exam next is Advanced
executive program in cyber security by
simply learn this course provides a high
engagement learning experience with real
world applications and is designed for
individuals who wants to start a new
more fulfilling career this Advanced
executive program in cyber security will
help you develop expertise in defensive
cyber security application malware
analysis ethical hacking Etc this cyber
security program developed in
collaboration with triple ID Bangalore
and npci helps to gain a strong
understanding of identifying potential
opportunities for innovation in cyber
security industry moving on to the next
certifications that is
ejptv2 certification is a well designed
to access your Proficiency in all stages
of penetration testing life cycle
including assessment methodologies host
and networking auditing host and network
penetration testing Etc its exam
includes 35 questions and you need to
score at least 70 percent to pass you
have a 48 hour time frame to complete it
so these were some of the best
certifications that you can opt for
alright guys with that we have come to
the end of this video If you like this
video please give it a thumbs up I hope
it really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
if you like this video subscribe to the
simply learned YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos turn it up
and get certified click here